in this lesson we're talking about some
examples involving foiling and factoring
so this is definitely important concept
to understand for the s80 let's go in
through these examples and see if you
can pause the video do them on your own
and we'll go through them together so
the first example it says if the
quantity C X plus 3 times the quantity
DX plus 4 equals 6x squared plus CX plus
12 for all values of X and C plus D
equals 5 what are two possible values
for e okay this guy right here okay and
then we've got some multiple choice
answers so go ahead and pause the video
see if you can do this one on your own
so the first thing to to realize here is
that you know when you the foiling what
do you do you take the first term times
the first term right so that's going to
be C times D times x squared right then
when you do the outside you get for CX
and you do the inside which is 3 DX and
then you do the last term's 3 times 4
which is 12 now if you're matching up
this expression with this expression you
can see 12 and 12 ok those match up
nicely here you've got see time Andy has
to equal six right so the only way that
C times D quit equals six is if C is six
and D is one right or vice versa or two
and three but you see how it says that C
plus D has to equal five so the only way
that two numbers are ab25 but multiply
to six would be two and three right so
basically what you can see here is that
let's go ahead and make c2 for example
so that be 2x plus 3 and then d would be
three so that be 3x plus 4 or we can
have the other scenario where V is 3 and
d is too so you can see if you check the
inside that's 9x plus 8x that's going to
give you 17 X so that's the middle
coefficient here 17 or you're going to
have 6x plus 12x which is 18 X right for
the middle coefficient for letter e
looks like the best answer here is going
to be letter D 17 okay and 18 would be
the two possible values so that's just
going through the multiplying the
foiling which they sometimes use this
afternoon first outer inner and last and
that's just saying you know first times
first outer those one towards the
outside enter those are the ones
multiplied together towards the inside
and then last term here times the last
term here it's just a way of remembering
it so that was a good problem now the
next example if c is less than 0 and c
squared minus 25 equals 0 what is the
value of C okay so go ahead and pause
the video so you can do that when I'm
your own well here's the thing you see
how this is a difference of two squares
so there's a formula you might want to
memorize okay or if you don't remember
from your algebra class it's a squared
minus B squared you can factor this as a
plus B a minus B so it's the sum and
difference pattern right so in this case
here you can pasture this as C plus 5
times C minus 5 equals 0 and then if you
set each of these groups equal to 0 c
plus 5 equals 0 and c minus 5 equals 0
and you saw all those you're going to
get negative 5 or positive 5 but see how
it says that c is less than 0 this one
is greater than 0 so our answer is going
to be negative 5 okay last example in
this lesson example 3 it says which is
equivalent to four x squared plus 20 X Y
squared plus 25 y to the fourth is it a
B C or D so go ahead and pause the video
see if you can do this one on your own
and we'll go through it together there's
a couple different ways to do this
problem one way to do it is you know you
could take these quantities here and you
can see there's squared so when you
square something it just means you know
you're multiplying it by itself like
you've got two of them and you could
spoil it out that's one way to do it and
that's not a bad way to go the other way
to do it is you could take a look at
this quantity here and you could faster
it and see which one it matches up with
here right one of these quantities now
one thing that you're going to notice
here is that there's something called a
perfect square trinomial it's a squared
plus 2 a B plus B
when you see this pattern you can factor
it as a plus B the quantity squared or
if you have a squared minus 2 a B plus B
squared and this is going to factor as a
minus B the quantity squared I'll show
you what I mean so here you can see that
this is a perfect square because 2x
times itself right giving you 4 x
squared and then this is a perfect
square because you can see 5y squared
times itself 50 x squared x 5 x squared
gives you 25 y to the fourth and the
only thing that we're checking now is
this inside product which is 10 x y
squared + 10 X Y squared which adds up
to the middle term which is 20 X Y
squared so these are both positive so
because we have the same quantity twice
we can write this as 2x plus 5y squared
squared because we have two of them so
it looks like the best answer would be
letter B so you can either do this like
by foiling by multiplying these
quantities times themselves twice or you
can go the other way and factor it and
see which ones match up but in either
case understanding how to use the foil
and a faster ring for the s80 is an
important asset to understand so go
ahead and review this lesson if you need
to otherwise I'll see you in the next
lesson